aquí nos dicen que liliana puede lavar
95 automóviles en 5 días
cuántos automóviles puede lavar liliana
en 11 días como siempre pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo ustedes
primero bueno la forma en la que me
gustaría que abordáramos el problema es
que si nos dan esta información es decir
95 automóviles en 5 días primero podemos
calcular cuántos automóviles puede lavar
en un día y eso lo multiplicaremos por
11 para saber cuántos pueden lavar en 11
días vamos a ver ella lava 95
automóviles en 5 días y ahora en lugar
de cinco
queremos saber cuántos lava en un día
entonces al pasar de cinco días a uno
vamos a dividir entre cinco así que el
número de automóviles que pueden lavar
en un día es 95 entre 5 en los dos casos
dividimos entre 5
cuánto es 95 entre 5 bueno tal vez ya se
hayan dado cuenta de que 5 por 20 es
igual a 100 por lo que 5 por 1995 ella
puede lavar 19 automóviles en un día
pero si hice el cálculo muy rápido y no
me entendieron aquí simplemente
dividimos 95 entre 5 y como 5 sólo cabe
una vez en 9 entonces ponemos 1 y 1 por
55 y si lo restamos
9 - 5 es 4 bajamos este otro 5 y sabemos
que el número 5 caben 9 veces en el 45 o
dicho de otra manera 9 por 5 es 45 y así
no nos queda residuo todo lo que hicimos
fue dividir estos dos números entre 5
para saber cuántos automóviles puede
lavar liliana en un día y ya vimos que
ella puede lavar 19 automóviles por día
pero no
nosotros queremos saber cuántos puede
lavar en 11 días
entonces en 11 días ahora vamos a
multiplicar por 11 si multiplicamos 19
por 11 cuánto nos da bueno si son buenos
en hacer cálculos mentales tal vez se
den cuenta de que 19 por 10 es 190 y nos
falta otro 19 así que en total son 209
automóviles o simplemente podemos
multiplicar 19 por 11 1 por 19 es 19 y
nuevamente 1 por 19 es 19 si lo sumamos
nos queda 209 así que ella puede lavar
209 automóviles en 11 días hagamos otro
ejemplo
aquí nos dicen que en el mercado ocho
baterías cuestan 10 pesos cuánto cuestan
seis baterías box en el vídeo y traten
de resolver vamos a aplicar la misma
técnica si ocho baterías cuestan 10
pesos
primero calculemos cuánto cuesta cada
batería entonces una batería cuesta
cuánto vamos a ver para pasar de 8 a 1
necesitamos dividir entre 8 entonces qué
pasa cuando dividimos 10 entre 8 ese es
el costo por batería 10 entre 8 es lo
mismo que si decimos 5 entre 4 que es lo
mismo que si decimos un entero un cuarto
y si hablamos de dinero lo podemos
escribir como 1.25 así que una batería
cuesta un peso con 25 centavos y si
queremos saber cuánto cuestan seis
baterías vamos a escribirlo seis
baterías
aquí simplemente vamos a multiplicar por
6 entonces cuánto es 1.25 por 6 vamos a
ver aquí serían 6 pesos más un peso con
50 centavos porque 6 por 25 es 150 por
lo tanto seis baterías cuestan 7 pesos
con 50 centavos para estar seguros de
que el cálculo está bien vamos a
multiplicar un peso con 25 centavos por
6 entonces 6 por 5 es 30 6 por 2 es 12
más 3 que ya teníamos es 15 y 6 por 1 es
6 +1 es 7 y tenemos dos cifras después
del punto decimal
ahí lo tiene 7 pesos con 50 centavos hay
otra forma en la que podemos resolver
esto podemos decir que seis baterías van
a costar seis octavos de lo que cuestan
ocho baterías pero eso es más confuso
para mí por eso prefiero conocer primero
el precio por unidad en este caso el
precio por batería y después lo
multiplicamos por 6 eso me da más
tranquilidad de saber lo que estoy
haciendo
nos vemos en otro vídeo